Psychopaths I don't I say this I hope
non naively also having dealt with
Psychopaths in my clinical practice and
I would say now and then in my life I
don't believe in Psychopaths I don't
believe that we know enough to say there
are people born without conscience I
don't think the psychometric measurement
of psychopathy is everything that it
should be I've been trying to model it
they in the Big Five domain I think now
it's complicated because so I would say
a psychopath the classic psychopath is
likely extroverted especially assertive
disagreeable and unconscious and maybe
extremely low in neuroticism so you
can't frighten them but so that's a rare
combination because it's extreme on many
traits right but that I don't believe
that that means that someone with that
personality configuration is doomed from
birth to a pathological existence
because there's things about psychopathy
that that the that the classifiers those
who claim like correctly that the
psychopath is born in some sense can't
explain it's like well what about the
cruelty there seems to be a motive
they're you know they're passionless and
they lack no they lack emotion well why
are they cruel then for entertainment
well but then you have to explain the
entertainment motivation like there's a
failure in some sense with the classic
psychopathy theorist to come to grips
with the problem of malevolence it
skirted over and you can't do that if
you're talking about psychopathy it's
like malevolence is the bloody issue
here and so the other issue with this
psychopath is that he's irredeemable
right that's the idea I don't think we
know enough to make such claims now and
that doesn't I know the psych office a
literature quite well and I have great
respect for their primary research is in
the field I want to make that perfectly
clear but we're talking at a different
we're talking we're approaching the
problem from a different level of
analysis here something like a spiritual
level of analysis and I don't think that
there's an easy easy translation from
the descriptive psychometric
theatrical to the spiritual level they
don't match and I'm more likely to say
let's not assume the soul is doomed from
birth right and I'm loathe to think that
there are people born irredeemable
although I do think there are
irredeemable people you know the death
penalty issues interesting in that
regard you know because I've read a lot
about really terrible people and I've
also read a lot about what really
terrible people said about themselves
and many of them wished for the death
penalty and so it's absolutely clear
that there are things that you can do
that deserve the death penalty but that
doesn't mean that the state should have
the right to impose it that's a
different question
so yeah
[Applause]